Let's take a look at my solution.
So the first thing I do is assert that the length of the graph is equal to the length of the cover
since we need the same number of nodes and vertices in both the cover and the graph.
We set n equal to length of the graph then.
So we go through every element in the adjacency matrix one by one
and if the element is at 1, that is there's an edge between those two vertices,
and either the first vertex which I think is not equal to 1, that is it is not part of the vertex cover
or the second vertex it isn't, then we return false.
And we check every single one of those and if we fall through all of those, then we go ahead
and return true and then it is a valid vertex cover.
Now for the naive vertex cover algorithm, what we do is first
for every assignment and a product of 0's or 1's
that is of length n, that's what this product statement does.
And if the validity check is true for that assignment and that input graph,
then we set the size to be the sum of the number of 1's in the assignments.
So we add up all the elements in that list, all the 0's and 1's.
Now if the minimum vertex cover is greater than the size, then we set that to be the size.
We update it, otherwise, we leave it alone.
Once we've look through every possible assignment
and remember there are a lot of possible assignments,
then we return the minimum vertex cover.